winning time we'll have a second season
on hbo and you know a lot of people in
the laker family disputed how they were
portrayed right
well now they're telling their own story
in a new docu-series
the camera on my face
once we got kobe on the team all hell
broke blue i am that killer snake relax
i'm still in charge
kobe and shaq's relationship along with
other untold laker stories are featured
in the new 10-part docu-series legacy
the true story of the la lakers out
monday on hulu it's directed by training
day's antoine fuqua to wear purple and
gold it's a different feeling
there was no ill will and we were out
there to win there's always tension when
greatness is being formed and any
adversity that we experienced
it always ties back to winning the woman
in charge of the 17-time nba champions
genie buss she honors kobe's legacy each
and every day
he set the bar i will always be inspired
by him it's about
challenging yourself you know what did
you do today to be better
[Music]